The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN: So welcome to
our special class with half the
people gone for
tonight's hearing.
You guys are the chosen few,
so I'm pleased you're here.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN: So I'm just
going to say a little bit
about models versus
data and then
I'm going to go back to
undervalue problems and talk
a little bit about how you
handle really big ones.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are these
going to be [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: All right.
WILLIAM GREEN:
And in fact, these
are even going to
be on the video,
because the guy just
this fixed the video,
so it will be recorded.
All right.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
You said the video
was broken last time
so that recording didn't work.
All right.
So when we're talking
about models versus data
a really critical question
is whether the model
is really consistent
with the data or not.
And how do we know
this is really true?
So we talked about
how we can figure out
some sort of chi-squared
maximum that we would tolerate.
So the maximum that
we tolerate, we
call it Q, capital Q
in a lecture before.
And so if we can find a
chi-squared of theta that's
less than this, then
it's at least plausible
that our model is true.
Right?
Or, alternatively, if
all chi-squared thetas
for any value of thetas are
greater than chi-squared max,
then we would say
the model is false,
or something else is really
wrong with our experiment.
Right?
That's what we say
when we're saying
we have a maximum chi-squared
that we would tolerate.
So a critical
question with us is
whether we really
found the very best fit
value of the parameters.
In some simple problems you
might have linear dependence
on the parameters, and
then there's only one
best fit usually,
as Long as you have
a non-singular set of
equations and everything
we find there's no trouble.
However, more commonly
you have equations
which are singular
or close to singular,
and also you normally
have non-linear dependence
between the model predictions
and the parameters.
So, for example, I do kinetics.
We always care about the ray
coefficients, the K's and they
always come in inside a
differential equation.
Right?
You always have like
d concentrations
dt is equal to some
terms, and some of them
are, you know, k concentration
I times concentration j.
whatever one it is, ij.
Right?
You have a lot of like terms
like this by molecular reaction
terms.
And these K's, some
of them I don't know.
And so these would
be one of my thetas.
So this would be,
you know, theta 17
would be one of these K's
that I want to determine.
And when I have a differential
equation like this,
when I integrate
it, the K is always
going to come in
non-linearly in the solution.
Right?
So when I integrate
this solution,
even in the simplest case
you get things like c of t
is equal to ae to
the negative kt.
That might be a really
super simple case
if you have a linear kinetics.
The K is still coming
in non-linearly
to the predictions.
Right?
And if you have
anything complicated
you can't even write it down
in a closed form expression,
and you have to integrate
with oed45 or ode15s
and so the
relationship between K
and the concentrations
that you measure
can be really complicated.
So it's always non-linear.
In my world all the
models are non-linear.
And I think there's many
other situations like this.
So if you try to
measure a diffusivity,
it might be possible
to set up an experiment
where you'd expect a linear
dependency to something
you'd measure in a diffusivity,
but most likely not.
So most likely it will come
in non-linearly somehow
and you'd have
some model for it,
and you'd have a
non-linear dependence
between that number and the
numbers you would measure.
Right?
And almost all the
properties are like that.
So because you have a
non-linear dependence,
then you have to worry
about how many minima
do you have in your surface?
So chi-squared of theta
is a non-linear function
of a lot of variables.
And typically it won't
just have one minimum,
you'll have a whole
lot of local minima.
Now one of those is
the global minimum.
And that's the one
you want, that's
the very best possible fit.
But you normally won't
know how many minima it has
and so no matter
how many minima you
find you don't know
if you're done,
and you don't know if you
really found the best fit.
OK?
So just because all the
ones you found so far bigger
than chi-squared
max you might not
be ready to write
that article in Nature
to claim that the
laws of physics
are incorrect because
you're not sure you really
found the very best fit.
OK?
So that's one of
the many problems
of trying to figure out
if a model of the data
are really consistent.
Now that particular
one, you can overcome
if you can find a guaranteed
way to find the global optimum,
to find the very best
possible that there is.
And some people spend
their life working on this,
and one of those people
is professor Barton
in this department.
And so he teaches a
class on how to do this,
and there are actually
methods to do it.
So if you want to see
the application of this
to kinetic models
there's a paper
by me and professor Barton.
And the lead author is one
of his former students,
Adam Singer and J. Phys.
Chem. and it just shows how
you can use global optimization
to guarantee you have
the very best possible
via the parameters, and then
they'll show you what happens.
So this is a case where the
experimental data was measured
by one of my students,
James Taylor, and that's
the thing with the error bars,
and he did a lot of hard work
to make sure he had
pretty good error bars
and he really knew
what they were.
And so he had those points.
So he measured a lot of points.
This measuring a lot of
points is a key thing.
So it means his degrees
of freedom is very large.
Because he uses many,
many different time
points along the
way there and he
has error bars on all of them.
And so because the degrees
of freedom are very large
it actually makes it a very
good constraint on the model.
It tested very thoroughly.
Where if you only
measured one point,
then that's not a
very good constraint.
Now what James had done, and we
published a paper in 2004 where
he did it, where he said,
you know, when I do my fits
this is what I get.
I get these kind of
purple and green things,
and therefore they're all
outside the error bars,
and therefore I publish in the
Journal of Physical Chemistry,
I claim this model is wrong
based on my experimental data.
OK?
So we published that in 2004,
it was accepted by the referees.
It's in the literature,
you can read it.
Don't believe it though, because
Adam singer went back and did
global optimisation
using the same model
and his red line goes right
through all the points really
well.
Do you see that?
You can see the red line there.
See this red curve?
That's the true best fit.
And so all the fits
that James had found
were all local minima in the
chi-squared squared surface.
And when he actually
found the best fit
with Adam's fancy
method, then it
turns out that
actually the model
matched the data perfectly.
So that's definitely true.
So what we published
the first time
was completely wrong,
because we said
the model disproved the data.
But in fact the model
proved the data.
I mean the data
proved the model,
or was completely
consistent with the model
in every way in great detail.
So I was a little embarrassed.
So then James, also in the
same paper, had found--
and they measured
another condition
in a slightly different
case, and actually
was looking at a
different solvent.
And in this case he found this
green curve as his best fit,
and it looked
pretty good by eye,
though you can see
it sort of skittering
on the tops of the
error bar bands.
And so this is one
where he said, you know,
we do the statistical test,
there's like a 5% chance
that you would
measure data like he
measured if the green
model was the truth.
And so we said some
wishy-washy words in the paper,
basically because
we weren't really
if it was consistent or not
consistent with the data.
But in that case Adam used
his fancy global optimization
techniques and found that
James' fit was actually not
that far from the
global optimum,
and he got the red curve
there, marked by the red arrow,
and that one looks
pretty good, it actually
goes through the data.
But it doesn't
really do it right,
and found that the confidence
intervals are only 16%.
So it's only a 16% chance,
one chance out of six,
that James would have
measured the data he measured
if that model was true.
And now we're sure that we
have the global best fit,
so now we're, like,
thinking well,
you know, maybe we should
say that the model is not
true for this case.
Because it's an 84% chance
it's not true anyway.
So actually we got
it wrong both ways.
So in the first case
we said that our data
disproved the model.
And in the second case, we said
that our model was pretty good
with the data, but actually
they were both wrong.
So one was wrong that actually--
the data did prove the models
correct for the first case
and it actually looks a little
fishy for the second case.
So anyway this is just
a concrete example
to make you be a little bit more
worried about what you do when
you do these fitting things.
Now there's a variety of ways
to try to do the least course
fitting to try to find optima.
There was a guy named Carr
from University of Minnesota.
And he published
this [INAUDIBLE] way
to just try a whole lot of
different initial guesses,
and that usually works to
find the global minimum.
But if you really want to have
a guaranteed global minimum
that you're absolutely
sure is definitely
is the global minimum,
then you really
need to use global
optimization methods
and you really should
talk to professor Barton.
And for these kinetic
models he actually has
a distributed code called
GDOC that will just
find the global optimization
as long as you don't have
too many kinetic parameters.
I think if you go to about 6--
around 6 adjustable
parameters it can handle.
If you have more than that
then usually typically not.
Because the problem with
global optimisation methods
is that they scale
exponentially with the number
of adjustable parameters,
or the number of things
you're trying to optimize.
Now on the other
hand, if you have
a model that you
need to use more
than six adjustable
parameters to fit your data,
then you might want
to try to think
of a different experiment.
Because you know the famous
saying is like, you know,
give me N parameters
I can fit an elephant.
So if you have more
than six parameters
and you're trying to
fit some data set,
probably if you do it
right you'll find a fit,
but it may not really
prove anything.
So from that point
of view professor
Barton's code, GDOC, is
pretty convenient for doing
these non-linear optimizations.
So that's a code for non-linear
optimization with differential
equations embedded.
And they can be stiff
and they can be large,
it doesn't matter.
What really matters
it's just the number
of adjustable parameters,
that's the cost.
All right now there was
a really good question,
that you asked I think,
in class last time, maybe.
Maybe the time before.
And it was what happens--
so let's look at
different case you get.
So one case you get, you
know, if chi-squared square,
theta best, your best fit
parameters is a lot bigger,
think chi-squared max, then
you're ready to say the model
disproves it.
So that one you're OK.
If chi-squared of your
best fit is less than,
or significantly less
than chi-squared max--
it has be much less than
it, really less, not equal.
--then you're
really happy to say
that the models are consistent.
The model and data are
consistent to each other.
And, in this case, what
you would normally do next
is determine the confidence
intervals on the thetas
that you adjusted.
Right?
And if you read the chapter
in Numerical Recipes,
for example, some
of the notes online,
it could tell you
how to do this.
Right?
And so that was OK?
It's OK.
So the case that's
really problematic
is you find
chi-squared theta best,
and it's less than
chi-squared max,
so you think the model
is consistent with data,
but it's pretty darn close
to theta-squared max.
And so then you have to figure
out, well, the weird aspect
of this is I now have--
here's my famous plot of
theta one and theta two.
So I have two parameters
I'm adjusting.
If they want theta two,
here's my best fit.
My best fit.
If chi-squared
max-- if the curve
of constant chi-squared
max is something like this,
this is chi-squared of theta
equals chi-squared max.
If it's like that then
I have some big region
of a lot of different
theta values
that give pretty
good fits, and I'm
happy to draw
confidence intervals,
like draw lines here and
here, for example, and say
that's the confidence
interval on theta one,
and I'm all right.
OK?
And it's sloped
here so I might want
to tell people about the
co-variance between theta
one and theta two.
All right?
But I know what
to do, it's fine.
Now suppose this is the
case that's like this.
Where chi-squared theta
best is significantly less
than chi-squared max.
Now suppose instead
chi-squared best
was very close chi-squared max.
So then here is chi-squared max.
This is chi-squared of theta
equals chi-squared max,
this is the good case.
Here's the bad case.
So in the bad case, there
is some region of thetas
that the model is
consistent with the data,
but it's very tiny.
There's a little tiny
range of theta values
that would make the models
consistent with the data.
Now what's weird about this
is that my best fit, it's not
very good.
The chi-squared is
almost up to the maximum
chi-squared I would tolerate.
So it means my deviations
between my model and data
are pretty bad.
Like this plot actually.
OK?
And so I'm, like, you know,
it could-- it's possible.
I was a little bit
unlucky and my data set
is pretty far off but still
within the possible range.
And so maybe the model
data are consistent.
But then when I try to compute
the confidence intervals
on my parameters, there's
only a really small range
of parameters that are going
to give good fits here.
Because the best possible
fit is this red line.
There's no choice
of the parameters
that's going to go through all
the circles with this model.
So now I'm like,
what's going on here?
So if I went ahead
and do the same way
I did before, I draw my
confidence intervals like this
and say, OK.
Say, wow, I've done
an amazingly great job
of determining theta one.
I know theta one very,
very, very precisely.
And the same for theta two.
Here's theta two, it's
got to be in that range
and I've really
done a great job.
So I'm awesome.
But I'm only awesome
because my original best
fit wasn't very good.
So this might make you feel
a little sick in your stomach
if you're getting ready
to publish in nature.
Right?
And then if the reviewers
are on their game,
you might get something
really scathing
back from the reviewers.
So there's kind of two ways
to play it at this point.
One way is, you are absolutely
sure that your equations are
correct.
You are Sir Isaac
Newton, you have just
written the law of gravitation.
You are measuring the orbits
of the moons of Jupiter,
and you are sure that
your equations are right.
And so, you know, my problem
is my antiquated telescopes
of 1600 are not
that great, and so I
think I have maybe-- maybe
I misestimated my error
bars on my measurements.
Maybe I have some
aberration or something,
the angles are off, right?
My twisted telescope looks as
if the star moves or something,
right?
OK?
So that's one
possible way to go,
say I really believe
the model, and so I
believe this is the
truth, and I really
believe my chi-squared
max to be what it is,
and I double checked the error
bars and I think it's true.
So I think have done a great
job and I should publish it
in Nature because
I have determined
these parameters with
17 more decimal places
than anybody ever could before.
OK?
So that's one way to look at it.
The other way to
look at it is what's
recommended in the
Numerical Recipes book.
And they say don't use--
instead of writing the equation
to be chi-squared of theta
has to be less than
chi-squared max,
they say when you're computing
the confidence intervals,
instead write
chi-squared of theta
has to be less than chi-squared
best fit plus chi-squared max.
So they say don't use a
stinky little circle here,
draw a nice big
one around there.
And what is this saying?
I guess what this is
saying is I don't believe
that my poor agreement
between the model and data
justifies me declaring very
narrow parameter values.
So
I just use the kinds of
parameter value confidence
intervals that it would have
actually computed a priori when
I do my experimental design.
I think that's really how
well I can determine stuff.
And I think something is
wrong that my chi-squared best
fir is so bad.
Maybe I didn't do my
global optimization right
and so I have the
wrong parameters.
Maybe I mis-estimated
my error bars
and so my chi-squared
are all off.
Maybe-- I don't know
what else happened.
Something happened, and I
don't believe I'm that good,
so therefore I'm going to
quote much broader confidence
intervals, which means much less
precision in my determination
of parameters.
And that's what
the Numerial Recipe
guys recommend you should do.
But you know, it's up to you.
And I see it both ways.
So the people who won the Nobel
Prize for the dark energy,
do you guys know about this?
So if you ever saw
the data there.
So that's one where they said--
they were using
Einstein's theory
of relativity,
General relativity.
They say we believe Einstein,
we believe that equations true.
And we're not going
to, you know, the fact
that the data only
matches when you choose
a certain value of the
cosmological constant,
we're just going to go with it.
And we're reporting
that's the value
of the cosmological constant.
Now some other people might say
that's kind of goofy theory.
Einstein changed his
mind six times about
whether to put the
cosmological constant
in the equation at all,
so I'm not so confident
and I would report
something different.
But they went with their gut.
They said we believe Einstein.
They went with it.
The Nobel Committee agreed,
and they got the Nobel prize.
So you know, you're
taking your chances.
The Numerical Recipe guys
are more like engineers,
they say, oh, we don't believe
models that much anyway.
Let's just use more conservative
confidence intervals.
Any questions about this?
OK.
All right.
So now let's change topics.
And we'll change to
[INAUDIBLE] splitting.
So if you remember back when
we were talking about boundary
value problems,
we're often trying
to solve problems
that are like this.
All right.
So this is the
conservation equation
for a species in a
reacting flow situation.
So you have some convection,
you have some diffusion,
you have some reactions.
Now in my life I
have a lot of models.
I have about 200
species in them.
So this K is 200
different variables.
And then you have these
equations, and on top of them
you have [INAUDIBLE] equations
for that momentum conservation
and continuity.
And so this is actually a
pretty bad set of equations.
And typically the
chemistry is stiff.
Because I have
chemistry time scales
it'll be, like, in picoseconds,
sub-nanosecond time scales.
And I'm caring about
simulating-- well in my case
maybe I have an advanced new
engine burning some fuel.
And so we're running over a
simulation of a piston cycle,
maybe 10 milliseconds, but the
chemistry is sub-nanosecond,
so then you multiply it out.
So that's like I'm going to 10
to minus two seconds down to 10
to minus 10 seconds.
That's eight orders of magnitude
difference in time scales.
So I'm in a bad way trying
to solve this equation.
And I have 200 of these
guys coupled to each other.
And then I have to think
about what my mesh looks like.
And I'm trying to
simulate inside a piston,
actually I have a moving
mesh because the pistons
compressing, so the equations
are kind of complicated even
with what the mesh is doing.
And then I need a
bunch of mesh points
there because the-- do you
guys hear the Kolmogorov scale?
You guys learned this yet?
It's a scale like
the minimum eddy size
if you have a turbulent flow.
And that's pretty
darn small also.
So it might be sub-micron.
And so I have a
natural, lens scale
that's like microns maybe.
So 10 to minus six meters,
but the piston diameter
is couple centimeters,
so again I
have like four orders of
magnitude between the mesh
size I need to
resolve the physics
and the size of the thing.
So I need about 10,000
points across the cylinder,
but it's a 3-D problem, so I
need 10 to the fourth, times 10
to the fourth, times
ten to the fourth,
so I need 10 to the
12th mesh points.
And then I have 200 variables,
say variables at each mesh
point, so I have 10 to
the 14th stayed variables.
So how much memory you
have in your computer?
How much ram?
You have probably
like 16 gigabytes.
So you have ten to the ninth-
tenth to the ninth bytes,
is that right?
No-- what's giga?
Ninth?
OK, so you have
ten to the tenth.
Sorry.
Ten to the tenth
byes, but I have 10
to the 14th stayed variables.
So I have a problem.
So then you need to figure
out how you solve it.
So there's two schools
of thought of how
to solve these equations.
The school thought which
has actually been the most
successful so far, but
is not readily available,
is to get the
government to build you
the biggest possible computer
in the world with as much memory
as possible.
And then you can actually keep
track of your state vector,
all 10 to the 14th
elements, and you
reserve this whole computer
for yourself for, your know,
a month.
And just run it.
And you figure out
how to parallelize
all the calculations, and you
just use an explicit solver.
And so that way it's
just straightforward.
All you're doing is
you're computing,
you know y of T plus delta
T is equal to something,
and it's just an
explicit formula
ode45, fancy version of that.
OK?
And it's just algebra,
and you just add them up
and it's no problem.
But this is a limited
feasibility thing.
This only became possible
about three years ago
when they built a computer
that actually had enough memory
to store the state factor.
It's also-- if the equations
are too stiff it still
doesn't work, because the step
size and time step you need
to use is so small--
so say it's 100
picoseconds and you're
trying to get it out
to a millisecond,
so you need 10 to
the eighth something
time steps, which means you need
to double precision numbers all
the way through.
But if the government builds
you a 64-bit 128-bit machine
then you can do it.
But anyway this is like a
very special kind of approach.
So now most people,
including me I
don't have access to that
kind of computer power.
Actually if you want
to read about that
there's a woman who does
that, who is Jacqueline Chen,
and you might want to look on
the internet and see about her.
And somehow she became
buddies with the people
in charge of the
super computers,
and so they're happy to give
her a month of, you know,
the best computer in
the world every year,
and she runs some really
awesome calculation
that's exactly right.
Solves everything, has
all the state variables
ten to the 14th, and
that's fantastic.
And currently
that's the benchmark
for how people test approximate
methods for how to solve this.
Because she actually has the
full solution numerically
converged.
But this again is a
limited applicability.
So a lot of people are working
on approximation methods
to try to solve this equation
if I don't have access
to such awesome
computer resources.
And the general idea of them--
well the two ideas.
So one idea is somehow
get rid of the turbulence.
OK?
And so what they do is they
use a mesh coarser than what
you what you would need to
resolve the Kolmogorov scale,
and then they use
models for what happens
for itty bitty tiny eddies.
And those are called
sub-grade scale models,
and this whole approach is
called large eddy simulation.
And the idea is you keep
track of the large eddies,
the big recirculation zones
that's modelled explicitly,
but you don't keep track
of all the itty bitty tiny
swirling off little
eddies that lasts
for a little second, a little
bit of a period of time
before they dissipate
because of diffusion.
OK?
So that's the concept.
And there's, I don't
know, half of all
of the mechanical engineers who
work in large eddy simulations
are trying to figure
out how to do this.
Maybe Jim as well, I don't know.
No.
OK, but at least he knows
some of them probably.
So that's one whole branch.
It's to try to get
rid of the turbulence.
And basically that's
trying to reduce
the density of mesh I need.
So trying to get rid of this--
use the spatial mesh.
But the other issue
is the time mesh.
And the time is
even worse, right?
Because I said I have ten
to the eighth time points
and I only need ten to
the fourth spatial points
in the dimension.
So in some ways, if I can
do something with the time,
that really can buy me a lot.
I have eight orders
of magnitude I'd
like to try to reduce to three
orders of magnitude if I could,
that would be really nice.
That idea is to say,
well let's separate
the fast timescales from
the slow time scales.
And in fact all the
fast time scales
are mostly all chemistry,
particularly after I changed
the eddy simulation where I get
rid of the really small spatial
scales, then the time scale of
diffusion over this big mesh
is kind of slow.
And so I can go to a time
scale that's completely
controlled by chemistry.
So we already told you, how do
you solve stiff differential
equations?
Use a stiff solver, right?
And there are special methods,
there are implicit methods,
and there's specialized solvers.
And what they do is they allow
you to take larger time steps
than you would be allowed
to use with explicit methods
where you would run into
numerical instabilities.
If you try to use the explicit
method with a big time stamp,
it's much bigger than the
real physical time scale,
you'll get some
crazy oscillations.
But if we use the
stiff solvers you
can get away with
time steps that
are much, much larger than
the real physical scale.
So that allows you to go
from 100 picoseconds up
to maybe 100 nanoseconds.
Get rid of three orders
of magnitude of time step
by using a stiff solver.
So that's pretty good, three
orders magnitude reduction?
Well go for it.
It's not only reducing
the CPU time potentially,
but it's even more
importantly reducing
the number of points
you have to save,
because when you run this
calculation what Jacqueline
Chen ends up with is a list, y
at every x, xn, yn, el, times
e, something like this.
Alpha, I don't know.
That's the output
of her program.
OK, so how big is this object?
This is 200 times 10 to the
fourth, times 10 to the fourth,
times 10 to the fourth,
times 10 to the eighth.
Right?
That's how many
numbers she's going
to get out of her simulation.
So, actually, her
biggest problem
is not actually
solving the simulation.
As long as she can get the one
month of CPU time she's good.
She's got to solve.
Her Problem is how
to analyze her data.
Because now she
has this much data
that she has to
figure out to say
something rational about it.
And so she has like a
whole army of post-docs
whose whole job is trying to
invent new day interrogation
methods.
And also this data set is
so large it cannot be stored
on a hard disk.
In fact it cannot be stored in
the biggest farm of hard disks.
So she has to, as the
calculation is running,
send the data to different
farms of hard disks
around the world and
filling them completely up,
and then sending them to the
next one and filling them up.
So she has fragments
of this data
set stored all over the place.
And then if she
wants to make a graph
she has to have a special
graphs software that
looks inside this data
farm, get some numbers,
look inside this
data farm and puts it
all together in some way.
So this is a pretty
hard project.
OK?
Now if I can use
a stiff solver I
don't need to use
so many time stamps.
So I can get this down, say
10 to the fifth at least
I got rid of three orders
of magnitude in my data.
Right?
So now I just need
one data farm maybe,
instead of, you know, using all
the ones at Amazon and Google
own or something.
OK?
So this is a pretty big
advantage to do it this way.
Now the disadvantage,
as you know,
is solving implicit
differential equations
is way more expensive, right?
Because you have to solve an
implicit non-linear algebraic
equation at every time step.
And in this case it can be a
pretty complicated equation.
Because if I have this
many state variables, so 10
to the fourth, times 10 to the
fourth, times 10 to the fourth,
so 10 to 12th times 200, so 10
to the 14th at each time step,
that's my current state.
And I'm trying to solve a
non-linear algebraic equation,
10 to the 14th unknowns, you
need a pretty good solver.
I mean, I know backslash is good
and F [? solved ?] and stuff,
but I really don't think
it's going to work.
So that's a really
serious problem.
So the next trick is to say,
OK, well this stiffness is only
happening because
of the chemistry.
So I don't--
I could solve all of the
finite volumes separately.
So the idea is to
split the problem up.
I'm going to solve the chemistry
using a stiff solver only
at one point a volume at a time.
And then I'm going to do the
transport some other way.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to rewrite this equation
as My unknown is dy to t,
is equal to some kind
of transport term
and some kind of reactant term.
And this term is local.
All this in this
equation, this is really
same dy at position x depends
on this at position x.
Whereas if you
compute these guys
I need to do finite
differences or something
from adjoining finite volumes.
Right?
I have to do fluxes from
the adjoining volumes.
So these guys are
sensitive not just
to my local value of y
at this finite volume,
but also to the
neighboring values of y.
But if I don't worry about
them, if I break it up
I have this local thing
and this non-local thing.
This one is local, it's stiff.
This one is non-local,
but it's not so stiff.
And often it's linear
or nearly linear.
Because the transport
terms are mostly linear.
And so I can use--
I have specialized
solvers that people
have worked on for many years
for each of these things.
So for the stiff thing I
have things like ode15s,
I have DAEPACK and [? DASPAK ?]
and [? DASL ?] and sundials
and all those programs that
people have written and spent
a lot of effort to
solve this problem.
And similarly
there's a whole bunch
of people who have spent
their whole life trying
to solve the convection
diffusion problems,
the non-reacting flow problem.
And so I can use specialized
solvers that they have.
So I want to split this up.
And what I really
would like to solve
is I'd prefer to solve dy/dt
equals r and dy/dt equals t
completely separately
if I could.
Because I can use
specialized methods
that are the best for each.
So not to figure out,
well this is not really
the real equation because it
has both of them added together.
How can I handle that?
So this operator
splitting recipe
is solve dy/dt equals
to t for a while,
and at the end of this process
I'll have a [? yat ?] final.
And then I'll solve this
equation with y equals y0.
That's the equation system
of solving, of transport.
I do some transport for a while,
I get some values for the y,
then I take these
guys and I solve
the reaction equation starting
from y equals y final.
How to write this?
One or two 0.
OK?
And I solve this one for a
while and I'll get a different,
you know, a somewhat
different [? yrt ?] final.
All right?
And the simplest way
of putting things
is just keep going
back and forth.
Boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom.
And in the limit where I
make this t final minus
t0 to be very
small, then maybe I
might expect that they might
converge to the same solution
as the couple of questions.
All right?
So that's the concept.
Now, if you do it this way
it doesn't work very well.
You need to make this
delta t incredibly small
to get any accuracy.
However you can do a slightly
more clever version, which
is I saw dy/dt equal t
starting from yt0, so y0,
and I solve this to me y
at t plus delta-t over 2.
Then I solve dy/dt is equal
to r, starting from y of t0
equal to, call this y star.
y star and this I
integrate out to y
of t plus the full delta t.
I'll call that y double star.
And then I solve
this one again, and I
solve starting from y of
t0 equal to y double star,
and I integrate that out
for another delta t over 2.
And this one I
called my y final.
And that's the one I use.
So I take a half of
a transport step,
sort of like I'm starting
to do the transport,
then I suddenly-- oh, hold on.
I got you my reaction.
I do my reaction, then I do
the other half of my transport
after that.
And if you can do
the analysis of this,
it turns out this
thing converges
to the true solution
of the couple equations
with second order accuracy.
So you might make this
delta t, if I cut it
in half the precision
increased by factor of four.
If I cut if by a factor of 10
it increased by a factor of 100.
So this is looking more
promising as a way to do it.
This is the most
popular way to do it.
So this recipe here
for operator splitting
is called Strang splitting.
Named after Gill Strang,
he was a professor
in applied mathematics
department here.
Former head of CIAM,
the international body
for applied mathematics.
And also author of a
fantastically great
linear algebra textbook
which maybe some of you guys
might have seen
some videos of his.
So he invented this 1968,
I was five years old.
He didn't know
that his invention
was of any practical use,
being a mathematician.
So he just published that paper.
Now in the meantime, this paper
is like a citation classic.
It's cited like, I don't
know, 20,000 times.
He had no idea.
He never looks at citation
list, he's a mathematician.
So I was working on
this problem and--
let's see-- let's back up.
So this is how he
usually solves it.
Right?
We usually solve
the problems, the--
splitting, sorry.
Just be able to see it.
And we like to solve
it this way because I
can use specialized solvers.
I use a transport solver,
I use a stiff solver here.
This one I can
parallelize because I
can do a different ode
solution at each finite volume.
So if I have a big computer,
a big parallel computer,
say I have 10,000 nodes, I can
solve 10,000 finite volumes
simultaneously in this
step, so the CPU time
is reduced a lot because
it parallelizes easily.
So this is really popular.
This is the main way
that people do things.
And then in the
ideal case you do it
with a certain guess
of delta t, then
you try delta t divided by five.
And if you get the same
result then you publish it.
OK?
And you've converged
your solution.
However, what I found doing this
is I was trying to find flames.
I was trying to calculate
the positions of flames.
And what I found was that with
the delta t's that I would try,
sometimes I would get a
qualitatively different
solution depending on
the delta t I chose.
And so in particular
what I found
was that I was
solving burner flames.
So I have, like, a burner here,
and it had a flame on top of it
like this.
And there's two importantly
different cases.
One is where the flame is
floating above the burner.
And one is where the flame
kind of goes all the way
and touches the metal.
And you've probably
seen both those cases,
like a bunsen burner
or something like that.
Sometimes if you get the
flow rates high enough,
the whole thing lift off
and be floating there.
And sometimes if you
slow the flow rates down
they say that they will
anchor to the metal.
Some piece the flame will
actually touch the metal.
Usually it's like
if you have a--
a lot of times you
have a case like this.
You have like a metal
piece, metal piece,
here's your mixture coming
in, out here is the air,
and a lot of times the
flame will actually
touch this metal piece here.
You know, the flame
sort of looks like that.
Have you ever seen
a flame like this?
Anyways, this is a common
thing, anchored-flame.
If you just have a slow speed
burner that's what you get.
If you go high
speed on the burner
you can make the whole
thing lift up and sort of
dance around if you
look at the flame.
All right?
You could probably see
the same if you look
at a piece of wood burning.
If it's burning well the flame
will be lifted off the wood,
you'll see a gap between
the flame and the wood.
If it's not burning that well
you can see bits of the flame
actually touch the
pieces of wood.
OK?
So that's a very important
thing for a commission guy.
So was really-- to me
this is a big deal.
So when I solved it with
one choice of delta t
I get the solution.
When I solved with
another choice of delta t
I get the solution,
with a nice big gap.
Now they both can't be right.
And so I was a
little bit alarmed
because it's like, it's
really different, right?
So I thought, you
know, I didn't really
care that much about the
dynamics of my problem.
I just wanted to make sure that
the steady state flame I ended
up with was the right one.
So if you're interested
in steady state problems
this is a really
important thing.
You want to make sure that
your solution really converges
to the true steady state.
So what I demonstrated primarily
is the Strang splitting method
is not reliable to
converge steady state.
Now I believe I made
the delta t tiny enough,
probably I would converge
the [INAUDIBLE] steady state.
But I don't know how
tiny I have to go,
and I can't really judge
my convergence criteria
very well, because at
some point of delta t
is it suddenly jumps from one
solution to another solution
that's qualitatively and
completely different.
So the convergence is not
smooth and continuous,
it's like it's converging,
converging, converging,
jumps to some other solution.
And I don't know where
the jump happens.
And I don't know if
I keep going further,
will it jump to something else?
So this makes me very
loathe to publish the paper.
Right?
So I don't know.
So I was agitated about that.
So I start working on trying
to fix this splitting.
The problem was that
Strang is really smart.
So his splitting
method is really good.
It's stable, it's
pretty accurate,
it's really hard to
beat it actually.
And so I published the papers
and they were that good
because they really didn't
really improve it that much.
But then I had a
really smart post-doc
named Ray Speth, now works
in the AeroAstro department.
And he came up with a
different way to look at this.
And he said, you know, if I
had a problem that's like this,
I can always add
some constant to this
and subtract the same
constant from this,
and I'm really getting
the same problem.
And so now the thing
is, can I cleverly
choose this constant so that,
for example, my steady state
solution is going to be good?
So how to figure out
what constants to choose?
And so the methods where
you add these constants
are called balancing methods.
So it's trying to balance the
operator splitting scheme.
And what Ray's method--
pretty simple balancing method.
So this is called
simple balancing.
Let's see if I have a
slide that shows it.
There we go.
Here we go.
Simple balancing.
You choose a c to be the
average of your right hand
side at the previous time step.
OK, now idea here
is that as you're
getting close to a steady
state, the previous time step
is not going be that much
different than the current time
step.
And so this average
number is going
to stay more or less study
as you as you get close.
And so what you're really
doing is adding the, sort of,
the average of these
two guys to each of them
from the previous
step, and that has
the consequence of really
changing the solution.
So let me just show you.
So the left hand side is
what Strang splitting does.
The blue chips
are the transport,
and the green steps
are the reaction.
And what's happening is I
did a half a transport step,
then I do a reaction.
The reaction sort of jumps
me off the trajectory,
then brings me back
to the trajectory,
then overshoots because I do a
whole delta t step of reaction.
And then I have to do a
half step of transport back.
And so I get from the
black-- one black dot
is the first point,
and the other black dot
is what I call y final.
And that's showing what happens.
And it just repeats like
that over and over again.
And it makes sense.
If you're close
to a steady state,
then if I'd just take
one of these terms,
without the balancing
theta transport,
it's going to head
away from steady state,
because at steady state the
transport and the reaction
are balancing
against each other.
Typically you have
something transporting in
and is being consumed
by the reaction.
Or something is being
created by reaction
and is being transported away.
And they have opposite signs.
If I only put one in
that has a certain sign,
then I'm going to move
away from the steady state.
And then I need the other
one to bring it back.
And the reason why Strang
splitting has trouble
is it's doing these
huge excursions away
from the steady state
at each time step,
with the hope that it ends
up back at the steady state.
Right?
That's the way it's
supposed to work out.
And to second order
it does, that's
because it's pretty
clever about how it works.
But it does it's
crazy excursions.
Now if you have a
non-linear model,
the further you do excursions
from the real trajectory
the bigger the area you get.
So if you do that
balance method,
you can see what happens is that
when you get to steady state
all the steps are just moving
you along the steady state
trajectory.
They're basically
maintaining the steady state,
and that's because I added--
it's like transport
plus half of transport
plus r or something like that.
And what is it?
There's probably
a minus sign here.
And so I'm getting rid
of half of my transport
and I'm adding in half of this.
So I changed-- before I
had dy/dt is equal to t,
but now I have dy/dt
is equal to 1/2 of t.
I feel I need a
sign to stick here.
So half of t minus f of
r, something like that.
And the-- this can't be right.
I must have a sign.
Maybe this is not the
average it's a half.
It should be minus.
It's like the-- these
things should be added,
and these guys are
you cancelled out,
so basically [INAUDIBLE]
is going to be zero,
which it should be
as a steady state.
So I'm sorry, that previous
slide had the sign wrong.
This is what happens
as the solution.
If you do Strang
splitting on the left
you get more accuracy as you
cut delta t, but it's only--
it's not getting any better.
It doesn't matter if
it's near steady state
or away from steady state,
it treats everything equally,
the Strang splitting.
In the balance splittings,
as you get to steady state,
all of a sudden the errors
drive exponentially.
You see this litte
logarithm of the error?
Logarithmic plot.
So you get tremendously
great convergence
to the real steady state
once you get anywhere close
to the steady state.
Now the cost of this is that
because the formula, which
has a sign mistake I
think, it depends on yn,
it makes the whole thing
more numerically unstable.
Because it's like
an explicit thing.
We're using what happened
at a previous time
to correct our equation
for future times.
And so you are more likely to
get numerical instabilities.
So then Ray invented
an implicit version
of that, and also a
higher order method,
and that's called
re-balance splitting.
The equation is way
too complicated for me
to write down, since I can't
even write down the minus signs
correctly in this one.
But you're happy to read
the paper, it's in CIAM.
And he has the
equations for that.
And when you put the second
order one in, that's implicit,
then the thing is just as
stable as Strang splitting,
but it also has
this great property
that as you get
close to steady state
it exponentially converges
to the solution, which
is sort of like how Newton's
method is really so good.
It's sort of like that.
You get a lot more
decimal places really fast
once you get close
to steady state.
All right, that's enough.
Enjoy Thanksgiving.
I posted a bunch of
readings and things
about metropolis Monte
Carlo and stochastic stuff
that we're talking about next
week, and also a little bit
more about models versus data.
So do the reading
when you get a chance.
Say hi to your families,
say hi to your friends.
Have a nice time.